JAMES MOREHEAD:
All right, I'm very
excited for my fourth
Talks at Google to welcome
Kari Byron, best
known of course,
for the Discovery Channel
show "MythBusters,"
but she's done many,
many things since.
For over a decade, she's
been a strong presence
in the world of reality-based
science television.
She's hosted "Thrill Factor,"
"Head Rush," "Pumpkin Chunkin,"
"Large, Dangerous Rocket
Ships," LDRS, super cool.
She spent a lifetime acquiring
odd skills and interests.
After graduating
college as an artist,
she traveled the world, decided
to settle in San Francisco
to pursue a career
as a sculptor.
Which is amazing.
But ended up discovering
that handling poop,
eating bugs, wiring explosives,
and scraping chicken guts
off the ceiling was
a real dream job.
Perfect resume for Google.
All right, I'm very excited
to welcome Kari to Google.
KARI BYRON: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thanks for
bringing me out here.
I'm from the Bay Area.
So for me, I've
watched Google grow.
I mean, I came here
with Jamie for a photo
shoot you guys had when
it was like an open floor
with some cubicles.
And I was so impressed
because you had a candy wall.
You have grown a lot.
AUDIENCE: Candy
wall is [INAUDIBLE].
KARI BYRON: Yeah.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
So before we talk
about everything you've been
up to since "MythBusters,"
I have to ask, is your
job as insanely fun
as it appears, or are you
just some terrific actor?
KARI BYRON: Well, I'm
definitely not a terrific actor.
And if you look at
early "MythBusters"
you can tell how nervous
and awkward and bad
I am at talking.
It is really, really obvious.
My job is actually
very, very fun.
That is one thing that we
always had is "MythBusters"
was one of the few shows
that was on reality
that was actual reality.
When we were hurt we were hurt.
When we were happy
we were happy.
And you know, we were doing some
really fun, interesting stuff.
And when it was boring,
they would just edit it out.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And even
with all the set up,
with all the shows you've done
there's a lot of stuff that
gets filmed and done and they're
not filmed behind the scenes.
Is that stuff still fun?
Or is there any part of it
that's kind of like a drag?
When you hear actors
talk about the hours
of waiting in the trailer and
the drudgery of making a film.
Was it all fun?
KARI BYRON: Well,
we were all friends.
And we actually had chemistry.
So before we all had Angry Birds
so that everybody would ignore
each other, we had
these really fun games
that we would do when say
there was some sort of safety
protocol.
Like the bomb squad had a full
hour that they had to wait
and we were stuck in a bunker.
We would come up
with old timey games
like throw the rock at the can.
And we would have
so much fun trying
to see who could hit the can.
Like we always had fun,
even when some of the things
kind of dragged on.
We all had very similar
senses of humor,
which slowly got lower
and darker because that's
what happens when you
get familiar with people.
And we all just kept each
other very much in stitches.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
You went on to college
for film and sculpture.
You're most well known for your
science-centered programming.
How has your
background as an artist
influenced how you
communicate science?
KARI BYRON: Well, you know,
I come from a long line
of sciencey and arty people.
And I feel like they
are in the same vein.
It's all about
fostering a curiosity.
With art you're taking
an idea and you're
trying to explore it
in a visual way that
helps you come to some
sort of conclusion
or feeling about that question.
And science is the same thing.
It's just exploring
your curiosity.
The difference is I feel
like over time, science
became very sort of--
when I was growing up,
almost like clinical.
Where it was identifying
the parts of a cell.
Whereas when it really gets
fun is the way we did it
on "MythBusters" is where
you get really dirty
and you get your hands on it and
you do it the way you do art.
You know, you're
throwing a pot, you're
getting your hands in the goo.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So that kind
of builds into this question.
There's a perception among
some that science is not
a creative endeavor.
That creative people
pursue the arts.
What have you learned
about science,
especially past what
you get in high school,
about the creativity
of scientists
and those that pursue science?
KARI BYRON: Well, I think it's
pretty obvious in the tech
community, you guys
have figured it out,
that a great diversity
actually comes
to a better space in
solving any sort of problem.
So when you bring an artist
into a scientific field or vice
versa, you come up with
the most beautiful things.
Look at kinetic sculptures,
when you take science
and apply it to art and you make
these incredible moving pieces.
I think it works the same way.
You just have a
different approach.
And over the years, I've
learned that art and science are
pretty much in the same vein.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Intermeshed.
You've also emceed
some amazing events
showcasing student scientists
from the White House Science
Fair to the VEX World
Championships in Disney World.
Super cool.
What have you learned
from the students
that you've met over the years?
KARI BYRON: Never
underestimate young people.
Because they are so much
more sophisticated than I
was as a kid.
And when you talk
to a 12-year-old
you talk to them like
they're a 35-year-old.
I've learned so much from
them and their experiences.
Because everyone at
that age is so honest
and will tell you
exactly what's happening.
And they're so creative and
the world's just so open.
And it's just such a
beautiful way to approach it.
And I think sometimes
as we get older,
we lose that need
to be fascinated.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Well I can tell you,
we have thousands of
interns every summer,
a few are probably in
the audience right now.
And it's amazing
what interns can
accomplish before they've even
finished their college degree.
Very true.
So a lot has been written about
how you visited "MythBusters"
and never left.
For students that have
no idea what they're
planning to do with their
lives when they grow up,
what have you learned
about making the most
of unexpected opportunities?
KARI BYRON: Well,
I feel like I was
almost too young when I went to
college to truly appreciate it.
I mean, that might
be pretty universal.
But I don't think that I
was the kind of person that
took advantage of it the
way I probably would now.
For me, when I was
traveling that's
where I really learned
how to say why not
and to go for opportunities.
Because I was traveling
alone around the world.
I had a friend to
start with, but then we
went our separate ways.
And it was just the sort of
thing where you just have to,
even if it's scary,
you have to try it.
And I feel like that is what
led me into "MythBusters"
to start with.
Because I tried advertising
and I was bored.
And I tried all these
different careers.
And I just couldn't find myself.
And I came to "MythBusters"
in my late 20s.
But I was ready to
just work for free.
I was like, you know,
I will be an intern.
Because I want to do
sculpture and special effects
seems like an easy
fit, because you guys
get paid to do sculptures.
How did I know it was a
dying art at the time?
The practical effects were just
crumbling beneath the crushing
computer industry.
But I really, really
wanted to learn how
to have an interesting life.
And so I thought if I
just do it for free,
sooner or later I will
prove myself worthy
and maybe they'll pay me.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Now you had a
long run with "MythBusters."
Was there ever a point where
you wavered or it got old?
Or did you just manage to have
this incredible long run where
it was fun the whole time?
KARI BYRON: I mean, it
changed along the way.
It was its peak fun when we
had the least amount of cooks
in the kitchen where we were
just allowed to run with it
and kind of do what we wanted.
Whenever anybody tried
to mess with the formula
and tried to figure out
what makes it popular
and do more of that, that
was always a little hard.
Like for a while, they kept
trying to make us fight.
You know, like all of those
chopper shows were so popular.
So they would take me
aside, this was back
when Scottie was there.
They'd take me
aside and be like,
you hear what Scottie
said about what you did?
You know what she
said about your build?
And then she'd
take Scottie aside
and be like, oh, this is what
Kari just said about you.
And they'd try to
get us to fight.
And I'd be like oh,
you're probably right.
Your way is better.
And they're like no, no, no.
Never works.
We weren't falling for it.
We like each other.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So
you've already brought up
that diversity is so
important, combining sciences
and technology and genders.
So specifically about
getting more women
to pursue STEM, which is a huge
priority at Google and we've
got a long way to go, we've
been very public about that.
It's a persistent challenge.
What have you learned about
inspiring kids, especially
girls, to ignore
those stereotypes
or look beyond them?
KARI BYRON: I mean, I feel like
we've made a lot of progress.
I mean, not too
distant past I would
have been chaining myself
to other women trying
to get the right to vote.
And then my mom's generation
was burning their bras
trying to get me
to go to college.
And now we're here.
I don't remember
seeing a lot of women
in dynamic scientific
positions on TV.
If they were on a doctor
show, they were the nurse.
They were never the scientist.
They were never the smart one.
And now every TV
show you look at you
see actual women represented
in smart scientific fields.
And maybe by the
time my daughter
is a grown up
superhero women won't
have to fight in high heels.
Like I feel like
progress is being made.
I know that when I-- I don't
know if I am an expert in this
at all.
I do know that the
girls I talked to
at the White House Science
Fair seemed like they were.
They had it down.
I asked them what
got you into it?
And they all had these
great stories of triumph
to get to where they were.
But mostly, supportive parents,
especially a supportive dad
was really, really important.
Having role models they
could look at like people
like Ellen Stofan from
NASA, seeing women
like that succeeding
was really important.
Seeing themselves reflected in
the media was very important.
But also mostly it was being
able to find like minds.
You may be the only girl in the
math club at your small school.
But there's another only girl
in Minnesota in the math club.
And if you guys can
get online, which
is the beauty of the internet,
you can actually connect.
You can feel that support.
And maybe you can
help each other stay.
Because I feel like people
get interested in things
but fall away when
its hard or when
they feel like an outsider.
And if you're the only girl you
might feel like an outsider.
So you gotta network
and help each other out.
We, as women, also
have a tendency
to compete and tear
each other down,
and we've been raised that way.
Where as I think
we're trying very hard
to start being supportive.
I think every time I
meet a woman trying
to get into my industry,
people are always
trying to pit me against them.
Like ah, she's trying
to be like you.
Or her show's not as good.
I'm like a woman on
TV, are you kidding?
I'm going to call her and
if we can help each other,
this will be great.
I wouldn't be where I am
without people like Debbie
Myers from the Science Channel.
She's like, let's do a
show that inspires girls.
Let's do it.
She helps me out, and I'll help
her out any time she needs it.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
You've always struck me, we
were talking before about being
an accidental celebrity.
By that I mean you
didn't do theater.
I tried to Google it and then
I asked, no theater, no theater
background.
You weren't deciding
to be a star.
You know, and so you were
an accidental celebrity.
You gained celebrity
status by doing something
you were passionate about.
How different is real world
Kari from the brand Kari,
and is there any difference?
And do you even
think about that?
KARI BYRON: TV Kari
wears a lot wear makeup,
my clothes are generally
tighter on TV, I think.
Or maybe that's just cause of
moving parts for machinery,
I don't want to get hurt.
I wear a lot less dresses on TV.
That's about it.
JAMES MOREHEAD: But other
than that, the Kari Byron
we see on "MythBusters"
and "Pumpkin Chunkin," that
is, you feel you're
able to be who you are?
KARI BYRON: Yeah.
I mean, when we
started "MythBusters"
it's not like you have
an audience like this,
which would have been
incredibly intimidating.
You have a camera crew
that you're friends with,
and it's almost like
making a home movie.
And so it just slowly
became part of what I did.
And I don't live in the
Hollywood structure as well,
so I don't do red carpets
and that kind of fun stuff,
except for maybe
like once a year I
get invited to something
special and I'll go down to LA.
So I think that maybe
that would have fed
me more of the celebritiness.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Now, "MythBusters,"
I think you were on the
red carpet for the Emmys.
"MythBusters" never did win it.
Get nominated a ton,
did it ever win?
KARI BYRON: No.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All
right, if "MythBusters"
won an Emmy, total crime.
What would be your
acceptance speech?
KARI BYRON: Oh, they wouldn't
let me give that speech.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Pretend
that they would.
KARI BYRON: It's a small
amount of time, I talk so much.
Adam, would totally take that.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
You'd get the music.
That's it.
The best speeches get the music.
All right, so the internet does
not have a great track record
when it comes to the
online treatment of woman.
How has your experience
been with the online world?
KARI BYRON: At first I
had to get a thicker skin.
Because we had message boards
that we were encouraged
to be very interactive
with our audience,
because that was what
made "MythBusters"
different is that our
audience was part of us.
And you know, I got my
feelings hurt really
easily when people would--
I remember somebody called
me a bubble head and I cried.
I mean, it's just a silly
insult, but it was just,
it was a little tough.
But I grew a really thick skin.
And I just don't
read that stuff.
And I kind of laugh at it now.
You just don't engage.
And you definitely
don't Google your name
with the words "feet" or "butt"
or you and any male costar.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So in
a more positive light,
you've been on David
Letterman's Show.
That was a while
back, Google it.
It's cool.
KARI BYRON: That
my first interview.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
That was very early.
KARI BYRON: I was so nervous.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I could
tell you were amped up.
KARI BYRON: I was playing
with my dress the whole time,
my feet were sweating.
JAMES MOREHEAD: You've
hosted science fairs,
as I mentioned, at
the White House.
Many cool events.
What is the coolest door
that's been opened because
of getting some celebrity.
KARI BYRON: Oh, my
god, the White House.
I mean, I got invited to
host the White House Science
Fair because there was an
emphasis on women and girls.
And I was so humbled
by the experience.
It was so incredible.
I got to do this panel with
some really incredible women
and some girls that had
made it to the science fair
and hear all their stories.
And we just got to
sit around and talk.
And I walked away from
there just in awe.
And then the president
said my name out loud.
My mom and dad could
hear, which was amazing.
And then they ushered me
off to a little secret room
with [INAUDIBLE] and
all these fancy people.
And then the president comes
over and gives me a hug.
I was like what?
This is so crazy.
And then at one point I had
to go look for the bathroom.
They just let me walk
around the White House.
Like I was just walking
around looking for a bathroom.
Like kind of looking for
some like monogrammed M&M's
or something to steal, but I
didn't But then like John Kerry
just walks past me on his phone.
I'm like oh!
How did I get here?
JAMES MOREHEAD: That's
pretty hard to top.
Yeah, I would have to agree.
So on "MythBusters"
and "Head Rush"
you've had a chance to recreate
and test some cool science.
What is the most
unexpected result,
if you can choose just one
that surprised you and was
not what you were planning for?
KARI BYRON: There's so
many different ones,
and I've talked
about them a lot.
Like bull in a China shop.
I couldn't believe
bulls were graceful.
I couldn't believe elephants
were actually afraid of mice.
I couldn't believe that an
ancient Chinese system using
drums buried in the ground
actually would trigger,
you could hear somebody
tunneling from far away
from this old ancient system.
But the most
surprising I had was--
I don't think I ever
talked about it.
But on "Head Rush" I
had a science advisor
that had this experiment for
me where it was heating water
in sort of an Erlenmeyer.
And then he told me
to put a lid on it.
And I was like, I feel like
that's a pressure vessel,
but you know what,
you're the science guy.
And then my gut kept telling
me, this is a bad idea.
This is a really bad idea is.
He's like no, no, no, no, no.
I've done this before, I've
done it a million times.
I'm like OK, he's the
scientist, what do I know?
So I made this experiment.
And I put my head down
close because they
wanted to get a shot, and then
I stood up and it exploded.
And it burned across my stomach
so that the skin fell off.
And I have like kind
of a scar the shape
of a wolf, which
is kind of cool.
But it was a really
important moment for me.
Because it shook me,
because I feel like there's
this psychology that you think
if the camera is rolling,
you can't get hurt.
If the camera is rolling,
nothing can go wrong.
And I also, I
didn't trust my gut.
And I only got hurt in a
really uncomfortable way right
before you have
to go on vacation
to a Hawaiian island That sucked
because the skin was coming
off.
But it was a small price
to pay for a new awareness
where I could realize OK, you've
got to actually stay safe.
Even if the cameras are
rolling, trust your gut.
And just because somebody
has the credentials,
doesn't mean they're right.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So I'm going to
ask you a couple more questions
then open it up to the
Googlers, so start thinking.
Ask good questions.
So on "Pumpkin
Chunkin" and "LDRS"
you've had the chance to meet
some really interesting people.
And if you're not familiar
with "Pumpkin Chunkin," that's
this event where you hurl a
pumpkin really, really far.
Crazy.
KARI BYRON: By any
mechanical means possible.
So we're talking catapults,
trebuchets, air cannons.
It just, it can't
be like rockets.
And they've gone over
a mile, a pumpkin.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And then on
"Large and Dangerous Rocket
Ships," people take
pretty much anything
and turn it into these
ridiculous rocket ships,
and also have rockets
go super high.
So when you've met these--
both really cool shows,
check them out.
What have you learned
about the people
behind these crazy,
insane stunts,
now that you've had a chance
to talk to them and meet them?
What makes them tick?
KARI BYRON: I mean, I have
a great respect for anybody
who follows a passion,
especially weird passions.
And the fact that these
guerrilla engineers are just
sitting in their garage
and this is their hobby
to create a huge
trebuchet to lob
a pumpkin and their
whole year is dedicated
to that, it's so much fun.
Because they're the
good kind of crazy.
They're using science
and engineering
in a wild and cool way.
And they turn it
into a family event.
Like everybody
brings their kids.
And kids get into
the physics of it.
And it's some of that
unintentional learning
that I always love.
Where it's the cheese
on the broccoli,
it makes it taste good.
What, I learned something?
JAMES MOREHEAD: And on
your most recent project
with the Travel Channel,
"Thrill Factor," also very cool.
Looks like a blast.
How did you convince Tory
to vomit and pass out
on a stunt plane to show
the effects of G-Force?
KARI BYRON: I mean,
I didn't really
tell him to vomit and pass it.
That's wasn't like me.
JAMES MOREHEAD: It's
fantastic, watch it.
KARI BYRON: Well, Tory and
I are really good friends.
And we do a lot
of shows together,
because we're complete
and total opposites.
Its really fun.
And he was the one that
brought the stunt planes to us,
because he met a rich guy
that had stunt planes.
And he's like let's go out
there to Vegas and do this.
And I was a little dubious
because it seems crazy.
But Tory has a
certain kind of charm
where it's sort of
like his men friends--
you know men get where
they love each other,
but they want to
torture each other?
So we go up in the
planes and he actually
has a really great
resistance to G-LOC,
and he gets to the
point of fighter pilot
before he passes out.
And I think that made the
pilot sort of challenged.
He's like oh, you
haven't passed out yet?
We're going to
make you pass out.
And then after I watched
Tory pass out, tumble.
They basically just
turned off the engines
and let the plane tumble.
And it was insane.
And I look over and like
oh my god, that's awful.
How did he do that?
He's like oh, you
want to do it now?
It's like no, no.
Turned off the
plane, it tumbled.
Mind you, none of
this made it to air.
I've suffered for nothing.
Tumbled into the plane
and then just puked.
And then as I'm getting off
the plane with my puke bag
and the Travel Channel
crew is down there
they're like, all
right, so how was that?
I'm like [GAGGING].
We both had to sit-in
a dark room for an hour
before they could do
interviews and stuff with us.
And we had wanted to get the
plane part out of the way,
so we didn't do any of
the preliminary stuff
just yet like walking in.
And so I had to get
the puke out of my hair
and get the mascara
out from under my eyes
so I could pretend like
it hadn't happened yet.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So one
final question, then I'm
going to hand it
off to the audience.
So if you could have a cameo
in one of the following,
which would you choose
and why-- "Star Wars,"
"Star Trek", "Game of
Thrones," or "Sharknado
KARI BYRON: Now if it was
based entirely on fashion,
the dresses and the outfits
they wear "Game of Thrones"
is awesome.
But the women don't
fare too well.
It's a little violent.
So I mean, I would
clearly pick "Star Wars"
because like Leia is--
I won't spoil the news.
They're leaders, they're
warriors, and they're equals,
and they get to fly cool planes.
JAMES MOREHEAD: How has that
movie-- because we were talking
about this already-- how
has that movie affected
your daughter?
What impact did Rey have?
KARI BYRON: I have
a seven-year-old.
So when we went to see
the movie she had no idea.
She hadn't watched any
of the "Star Wars."
And we went with my nephew
who was five and so excited.
And we went to the theater
and she's like oh yeah,
this will be cool.
And then when it turned out
that Rey appeared and she
was the main character my
daughter yelled in the back
"she's a girl!"
Every body is laughing.
After that, she went home,
she made a wrapping paper
lightsaber.
And she just actually threw
away all her princesses.
Don't tell Disney.
We didn't throw them away.
We took all of our
princesses and we gave them
to a younger cousin.
And it was all
about "Star Wars."
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
That's cool.
Same thing happened
to my daughter.
So very cool.
All right, so I
have a helper here
with a microphone and the
Dory, if there are any Dory.
There are some.
All right I will-- just
go in audience first
and I will look
through the Dory.
The Dory, by the way, is
our internal mechanism
for people watching on live
stream to ask questions.
So I will look through those
for those on the live stream.
KARI BYRON: OK.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All
right, so we'll go
to an audience question first.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Erica.
I actually have three
daughters, seven, 10, and 12.
And also very similar to
you, engineering, arts sort
of by whole life I've
kind of been in there,
so I understand the desire.
I wanted to know
if you have heard
of what's called SheHeroes,
because I think that modeling
is sort of a really key
thing for our daughters.
And so there's a
program called SheHeroes
where people like you
and regular people
do little video
clips and give models
to young kids, young girls,
for like being cool and being
cool in science.
I was curious if you.
KARI BYRON: I
hadn't heard of it,
but I will definitely
put that on my looksies.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
KARI BYRON: I'll Google it.
AUDIENCE: Google it,
like having you involved
in that would be awesome.
SheHeroes.
KARI BYRON: Is that
something you do?
AUDIENCE: I am friends
with somebody who does it,
so if you want the connection
I'm happy to set you up.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All right.
AUDIENCE: But it is a very
cool program for anybody.
JAMES MOREHEAD: We've had
our first question and plug.
I'm going to the Dory.
So what's the
coolest skill you've
learned on "MythBusters" that
you've used outside the show?
KARI BYRON: Oh,
should I say this?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Now wait,
as soon as someone says,
should I say this?
The answer, of course,
we need to hear it.
KARI BYRON: Well, as
I love to do artwork.
I used to really
love the impressions
that black powder would make
after you exploded them.
So I do some black
powder painting now
at an undisclosed location
that is completely
safe and completely legal.
And it's really,
it's a fun medium
to work with when you
know how to do it safely.
And I learned how
to do it safely.
And I learned that
you can get anything
on the internet from China
for your artistic passions.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So I
have to build on that.
Because the explosions in
"MythBusters" in slow-mo
are phenomenal.
What is your favorite
all time explosion.
KARI BYRON: Oh, that's easy.
Because people always ask me
about my favorite explosions.
And you know, there's that
pushing power of AN/FO,
and then C4 is sort of
like a dirty quick one.
But like I love, it might
actually be an ignition.
But when we shot guns
at a propane tank
it made this gorgeous billowing
fiery probably not great
for the environment cloud that
in slow motion kind of rolled
and it was just beautiful.
That and coffee creamer
also an ignition.
When coffee creamer, we
exploded it into the air
and lit it with
a flare also just
like a fuel based kind of
Hollywood style explosion.
The kind of thing
that you actually
expect to see as an explosion.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
Audience?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what your
favorite myth was that either
never actually made it to
air or never got selected
to even be done at all.
KARI BYRON: We definitely
had a couple that
didn't make it to air either
because they were ridiculous
or we couldn't do them.
We tried to do this one called
squash weightlifter, where
the idea was that one of those
giant pumpkins from Monterey
had the capacity
to lift a car if it
grew underneath it, because
it had that kind of strength.
But turns out all of
us have black thumbs
and we couldn't grow anything.
And we had this
like garden set up.
We tried it twice, three times.
We had this garden set up
with the best hydroponics,
because San Francisco.
And its like crazy
grow-light disco den.
We had the seeds from
some champion pumpkins.
And we couldn't get
anything bigger then this.
And we tried and tried.
But it was really fun because
we had that crazy garden.
And I enjoyed the-- it
was a little zen going out
there and trying to garden.
But I guess the environment
just wasn't supporting it.
AUDIENCE: So recently
Google has been
doing things like Deep Dream and
Magenta with some basic forays
into AI creating art and music.
What would be some
combinations of science and art
that are just completely
side sci-fi that you would
like to see become reality?
KARI BYRON: I would like my own
slave robot android, for sure
that could light the explosions
in my black powder painting
closer than I could.
That is a very complex
question, I like it.
Have you ever seen, I think
they're called wind beasts?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Windibeasts?
KARI BYRON: Wind beasts,
those giant kinetic sculptures
that move in the wind.
That's my favorite kinetic
application of science to art.
I thought that was so beautiful.
AI scares me though.
JAMES MOREHEAD: These
aren't real people.
KARI BYRON: I mean,
wouldn't be surprised.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
We're actually, we're
testing the advancement of AI.
KARI BYRON: I'm the beta
tester on the scary AI?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yes.
We're going to go back--
KARI BYRON: They all
look like regular people.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Well, we're
going to analyze the laughs
and make sure they were laughing
at the appropriately part.
AUDIENCE: So are
there any scenes
from "MythBusters" that were
like edited out that you really
wish could have made it to air?
KARI BYRON: Oh, I
mean there's so many.
But I could tell you a
super embarrassing one
that was kind of funny.
There was a point where
we were out in the desert.
And tensions were high, it
was hot, people were fighting.
It got really sort
of just very tense.
And so I walked up into the
middle of a tense conversation
and just walked up to Grant
and went, put my finger.
[LAUGHTER]
And they laughed
very hard as I--
you know that means
you toot, right?
OK.
Well, I just felt like I
couldn't figure out anything
to make this better.
I was like nothing
better than a girl fart.
Girl farts are funnier
than dog farts.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I'm not
sure how to go after that.
So I'm not going to
pivot off the question.
So off the Dory,
what advice-- we'll
take a couple more questions.
What advice would you give to
a young aspiring scientists,
but I'm going to
modify it a little bit,
a young aspiring
female scientist.
KARI BYRON: Find a mentor
and find an internship.
Find someone doing what
you want to be doing.
Because likely, they
will help you out.
And people love talking
about themselves.
I've been doing it for
like half an hour now.
You can usually get
in good with somebody,
and they're likely
to help you out.
And everybody loves an intern.
They work hard.
They're trying to
prove themselves.
And they are cheap or free.
So you can get your
foot in the door,
you can get some
experience, find out
if it's what you
really want to do.
And I mean, that's how I
started on "MythBusters"
is just a lot of
exploiting of free labor.
AUDIENCE: So you started
with the sculpture
and now you've mentioned
like black powder
stuff, the kinetic art, is
sculpture still-- now TV, film,
et cetera-- is sculpture
still your favorite
or do you have a new
favorite type of art?
KARI BYRON: No,
I love sculpture.
I think in 3-D. Like I'm a much
better sculptor than someone
who draws.
If I have an idea of something,
how I want it to look at I
can make it clay better
than I can draw it.
So for me, it's very calming.
And I'm a bit of a multi-tasker.
So I will do sculptures while I
listen to podcasts or watch TV
or try to have meetings
when they are on not Skype,
because they can see that.
And I still make a lot of them.
And I use them as a
terrifying parental learning
tools for my daughter.
I make these things called
Manners Monsters or Behavior
Beasties to break her of habits.
Such as for a while she wasn't,
when she was much smaller,
she had a tendency not
to flush the toilet.
So we made a poop monster that
looked like it was crawling out
of the toilet, that I said
if it stays in there too long
it comes to life.
We had booger monsters that
you know, eat the boogers
in your nose.
And if you go in there
and steal their food
they're going to crawl out
your nose and look for food.
They might crawl in your
ear and eat your brain
and you'll never learn to read.
So we make the little--
I have monsters
for almost every bad behavior.
So I've got a ton of them now.
And they're creepy
and little kind
of Tim Burtony looking things.
They cured her of
nail biting real fast.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All right,
who would back a Kickstarter
campaign for a poop monster?
KARI BYRON: It's about
terrifying your children
into good behaviors.
JAMES MOREHEAD: We're
going to take one more Dory
and one more live question and
then we have time for a short
meet and great.
So I'm going to modify
this a little bit.
So what's the most
dangerous thing
not that you did on the
show, but that you didn't
do on the show
because you finally
figured out, this would probably
be too dangerous to film?
KARI BYRON: Anything
Tory ever suggest ever.
End
JAMES MOREHEAD: All
right, that's good.
We'll bring Tory
in for a follow up
and that will be
the lead question.
All right, we had one
more to the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Back to
the art side, I
do follow your
black powder work,
tried to dabble a
little bit in it myself
and caused a little bit more
fiery explosions probably
in not a safe manner as you.
But for the art side,
you've done a lot advocation
for technology, engineering,
and all of that.
How do you feel companies
like this, like we
have a maker space here.
It's called the Garage.
And do you try to advocate
that artistic side
towards a lot of those
ends too, those tech sides?
Because I feel like
sometimes that's
lost when there's a lot
of science and engineering
and all that, you
might lose some
of that ingenuity or the fun
of art that comes with it.
Is that something
that you often see
or is there anything
that advocating-wise
that you do on it?
KARI BYRON: Well, I love
living in the Bay Area,
because we are clearly a
strange bubble of people.
Here it's not STEM, it's STEAM.
We put the Art in the STEM.
Because I mean, mathematicians
are artists and scientists
are artists.
And I think that the maker
movement is incredible.
And I love how DIY and sort
of the whole sort of Etsy
generation is kind of bringing
it back to an arty form.
And the Maker Faire is
getting bigger every year.
And it's so cool to
see people applying
all of their different
brains into something
even that's ridiculous
but beautiful and cool.
I love the maker movement.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Well, I want to
thank you for an awesome visit
to Google.
KARI BYRON: Oh my
god, thank you.
JAMES MOREHEAD: It
was totally fun.
KARI BYRON: This
has has been fun.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Just
[? so you know ?]
that we fed Kari.
She didn't have to pay
for the food, shocker.
Took her on her tour, and
it was really exciting
to have you here today.
Thank you very much.
And good luck with-- I know the
things you can't talk about,
but Kari has some
cool stuff coming.
I'll leave it at that.
KARI BYRON: Are we talking
about our new show?
This week we make
an announcement.
So me, Tory, and Grant
are back together
in another nerdy endeavor.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.